[Musique]
c'est le deuxième soir consécutif
l'esplanade des invalides pris d'assaut
par des fêtards
près de 2000 jeunes mineurs pour la
plupart sans masque autres violations
des règles sanitaires le public a envahi
le terrain après la victoire du biarritz
olympique face à l'aviron bayonnais qui
permettent aux biarrots d'accéder au top
une ambiance un peu trop chaude qui a
choqué le préfet des pyrénées
atlantiques
il a d'ailleurs saisi la justice cette
fête avait été organisée depuis les
réseaux sociaux une soirée projet x du
nom de ce film américain où des jeunes
participent à une fête géante qui
dégénère gérald darmanin considère
qu'une une victoire dans une région du
rassemblement national serait juste une
marque satanique
qu'est ce que ça veut dire une marque
satanique c'est quoi la marque satanique
du rassemblement national
est-ce que vous avez compris ce que ça
veut dire moi je n'ai pas entendu gérald
darmanin prononcé ces propos j'ai déjà
je ne sais pas je vous le dis mais je ne
sais pas je n'ai pas entendu prononcer
ces propos ce sont leurs propos parler
de satanisme en politique
donc le gouvernement d' emmanuel macron
fait d'une surenchère et cette
surenchère
elle se traduit dans les faits et l'art
de la campagne vous n'ignorez pas
jusqu'à dire que le président aurait pu
qui a mérité entre guillemets mais
certainement pas je la condamne surtout
que ça s'arrête je serai pas mal bon
c'est la violence vous voulez il ya un
instant bronchait pas qui est la
personne
mais elle a réussi son coup parce que
comme vous êtes vous surpris par un g de
farine de monsieur mélenchon comme tout
élu d'ailleurs et appartements il est
victime d'une atteinte physique à son
intégrité physique
nous la condamnons voilà que ça vise le
président de la république que sa vie de
monsieur mélenchon aux élus du
rassemblement national
il faut vraiment que dans le pays à un
sursaut qui répondent à la situation que
nous en sommes en train de vivre un
déploiement violent de l'extrême droite
qui menace de mort qui frappe le
président l'extrême gauche pour moi même
si elle n'a pas du tout la même histoire
que l'extrême droite me paraît
aujourd'hui dans une dérive qui la rend
aussi dangereuse pour le pays que
l'extrême droite
un acte jugé lâche par le chef de file
de la france en soumises et subit aussi
quelques heures plus tôt à nantes
par françois de rugy candide lrm en pays
de la loire à l'extrême gauche il ya un
point commun c'est ce mode d'action qui
vise à nous intimider les responsables
politiques les élus les candidats en
campagne qui vise à nous empêcher à nous
empêcher d'aller voir les gens ont des
placements à péronne dans la somme eric
dupond-moretti c# avec le candidat du
rassemblement national dans le
département
damien rieu données envoyées justice en
204 ça qu'on défend et vous voyez c'est
pas envie de faire le kéké sur le marché
il a aujourd'hui gagné 50 mille emplois
industriels qui ont disparu nos pays
vous êtes ministre de l'industrie et est
ce que vous faites
on soit rufin pour ce qui est de faire
de l'animation folklorique plutôt que de
travailler le fond des idées
il s'y connaît bien j'ai siégé à
l'assemblée nationale avec lui pendant
deux heures et demie je peux vous dire
que il sait ce que c'est que de faire du
montage vidéo plutôt que de faire 2
l'argument politique monsieur rufin dans
notre pays on voit une montée des
violences
on a tous des raisons qui sont propres à
nos pays mais elles ont des racines
profondes les inégalités sécrétée par le
fonctionnement de l'économie
internationale et l'ensauvagement des
discours sur les réseaux sociaux